so i'll be speaking to you using
language because i can
this is one of these magical abilities
that we humans have
we can transmit really complicated
thoughts to one another so what i'm
doing right now is i'm making sounds
with my mouth as i'm exhaling i'm making
tones and hisses and puffs and those are
creating air vibrations in the air
those air vibrations are traveling to
you they're hitting your eardrums and
then your brain takes those vibrations
from your eardrums and transforms them
into
thoughts
i hope
right i hope that's happening
so
because of this ability we humans are
able to transmit our ideas across vast
switches of space and time right we're
able to transmit knowledge across uh
across minds i can put a bizarre new
idea in your mind right now i could say
imagine a jellyfish waltzing in a
library while thinking about quantum
mechanics
now if everything has gone relatively
well in your life so far you probably
haven't had that thought before
but now i've just made you think it
through language right
now of course there isn't just one
language in the world there are about
7000 languages spoken around the world
and all the languages differ from one
another in all kinds of ways some
languages have um
different sounds they have different
vocabularies and they also have
different structures very importantly
different structures
that begs the question does the language
we speak shape the way we think
now this is an ancient question people
have been speculating about this
question for forever
charlemont holy roman emperor said to
have a second language is to have a
second soul
strong statement that language crafts
reality
but on the other hand shakespeare has
juliet say
what's in a name a rose by any other
name would smell as sweet
that suggests that maybe language
doesn't craft reality
these arguments have gone back and forth
for uh thousands of years
but until recently there hasn't been any
data to help us decide either way
recently in my lab and other labs around
the world we've started doing research
and now we have actual scientific data
to
weigh in on this question
so let me tell you about some of my
favorite examples
i'll start with an example from an
aboriginal community in australia that i
had a chance to work with these are the
kooktair people they live in pomparau at
the very west edge of cape york
and what's cool about kooktai or is
in quicktire they don't use words like
left and right
and instead everything is in cardinal
directions north south east and west
and when i say everything i really mean
everything you would say something like
oh there's a an ant on your southwest
leg
uh or move your cup to the north
northeast a little bit in fact the way
that you say hello and quick tire is you
say which way are you going and the
answer should be
north northeast in the far distance how
about you
so
imagine as you're walking around your
day every person you greet you have to
report your heading direction
that would actually get you oriented
pretty fast right because you literally
couldn't get past hello uh if you didn't
know which way you were going
uh in fact people who speak languages
like this stay oriented really really
well they stay oriented better than we
used to think humans could uh we used to
think that humans were worse than other
creatures because
some biological excuse oh we don't have
magnets in our beaks or in our scales no
if your language and your culture trains
you to do it actually you can do it
there are humans around the world who
stay oriented really well
and just to get us
in agreement about how different this is
from the way we do it i want you all to
close your eyes for a second
and point southeast
now keep your eyes closed point
okay so you can open your eyes i see you
guys pointing there there there there
there
i don't know which way it is myself
you have not been a lot of help
so let's just say the accuracy in this
room was not very high this is a big
difference in cognitive ability across
languages right where one group a very
distinguished group like you guys
doesn't know which way is which but in
another group i could ask a
five-year-old and they would know
there are also really big differences in
how people think about time so here i
have pictures of my grandfather at
different ages and if i ask an english
speaker to organize time they might lay
it out this way from left to right this
has to do with writing direction if you
were speaker of hebrew arabic you might
do it going in the opposite direction
from right to left
uh how would the kooktai or this
aboriginal group i just told you about
do it they don't use words like left and
right
let me give you a hint
when we sat people facing south
they organized time from left to right
when we sat them facing north
they organized time from right to left
when we sat them facing east
time came towards the body
what's the pattern
east to west right so for them time
doesn't actually get locked on the body
at all it gets locked on the landscape
so for me if i'm facing this way then
time goes this way and if i'm facing
this way then time goes this way i'm
facing this way time goes this way
very egocentric of me to have the
direction of time chase me around every
time i turn my body
for the kook tired time is locked on the
landscape it's a dramatically different
way of thinking about time here's
another really smart human trick suppose
i ask you how many penguins are there
well i bet i know how you'd solve that
problem if you solved it you went one
two three four five six seven eight you
counted them right you named each one
with a number and the last number you
said was the number of penguins now this
is a little trick that you're taught to
use as kids you learn the number list
and you know you learn how to apply it a
little linguistic trick
well some languages don't do this
because some languages don't have exact
number words
they're languages that don't have a word
like seven or a word like eight
and in fact people who speak these
languages don't count and they have
trouble keeping track of exact
quantities so for example if i ask you
to match this number of penguins to the
same number of ducks
you would be able to do that by counting
but folks who don't have that linguistic
trick can't do that
language is also different how they
divide up the color spectrum the visual
world
some languages have lots of words for
colors some have only a couple words
light and dark and languages differ in
where they put boundaries between colors
so for example in uh english there's a
word for blue that covers all of the
colors that you can see on the screen
but in russian there isn't a single word
instead russian speakers have to
differentiate between light blue glow
boy and dark blue cine
so russians have this lifetime of
experience of in language distinguishing
these two colors
when we test people's ability to
perceptually discriminate these colors
what we find is that russian speakers
are faster across this linguistic
boundary they're faster to be able to
tell the difference between a light and
a dark blue
and when you look at people's brains as
they're looking at colors say you have
colors shifting slowly from light to
dark blue
the brains of people who use different
words for light and dark blue will give
a surprise reaction as the colors shift
from light to dark as if oh something
has categorically changed
whereas the brains of english speakers
for example that don't make this
categorical distinction don't give that
surprise because nothing is
categorically changing
languages have all kinds of structural
quirks this is one of my favorites lots
of languages have grammatical gender so
every noun gets assigned a gender often
masculine or feminine and these genders
differ across languages so for example
the sun is feminine in german but
masculine in spanish and the moon the
reverse
could this
actually have any consequence for how
people think do german speakers think of
the sun as some somehow more female like
the moon somehow more male like
actually it turns out that's the case so
if you ask german and spanish speakers
to say describe a bridge like the one
here
bridge happens to be uh grammatically
feminine in german grammatically
masculine in spanish german speakers are
more likely to say bridges are beautiful
elegant these stereotypically feminine
words
whereas spanish speakers will be more
likely to say they're strong or long
these masculine words
languages also differ in how they
describe events right so you take an
event like this an accident in english
it's fine to say he broke the vase
in
a language like spanish you might be
more likely to say the vase broke or the
vase broke itself
if it's an accident you wouldn't say
that someone did it in english quite
weirdly we can even say things like i
broke my arm
now in lots of languages you couldn't
use that construction unless you are a
lunatic and you went out looking to
break your arm and you succeeded right
if it was an accident you would use a
different construction
now this has consequences so uh people
who speak different languages will pay
attention to different things depending
on what their language usually requires
them to do so
we show the same accident to english
speakers and spanish speakers english
speakers will
remember who did it
because english requires you to say he
did it he broke the vase where spanish
speakers might be less likely to
remember who did it if it's an accident
but they're more more likely to remember
that it was an accident they're more
likely to remember the intention
so
two people watched the same event
witness the same crime
but end up remembering different things
about that event
this has implications of course for
eyewitness testimony
it also has implications for blame and
punishment so if you take english
speakers and i just show you someone
breaking a vase and i say he broke the
vase as opposed to i say the vase broke
even though you can witness it yourself
you can watch the video you can watch
the crime against the vase
you will punish someone more you will
blame someone more if i just said he
broke it as opposed to it broke right
the language guides our reasoning about
uh events
now
i've given you a few examples of how
language can profoundly shape the way we
think and it does so in a variety of
ways
so language can have big effects like we
saw with space and time where people can
lay out space and time in completely
different coordinate frames from each
other
language can also have really deep
effects that's what we saw with the case
of number
having count words in your language
having number words opens up
the whole world of mathematics of course
if you don't count you can't do algebra
you can't do any of the things that
would be required to build a room like
this or make this broadcast right
this little trick of number words gives
you a stepping stone into whole
cognitive realm
language can also have really early
effects what we saw in the case of uh
color right uh these are really simple
basic perceptual decisions we make
thousands of them all the time and yet
language is getting in there and uh
fussing even with these tiny little
perceptual decisions that we make
language can have really broad effects
so the case of grammatical gender may be
a little silly but at the same time
grammatical gender applies to all nouns
that means language can shape how you're
thinking about
anything that can be named by a noun
it's a lot of stuff
and finally i gave you an example of how
language can shape things that have
personal weight to us ideas like blame
and punishment or eyewitness memory
these are important things in our daily
lives
now the beauty of linguistic diversity
is that it reveals to us
just how ingenious and how flexible the
human mind is
human minds have invented not one
cognitive universe but seven thousand or
seven thousand languages spoken around
the world
and we can create many more languages of
course are
living things things that we can hone
and
change to suit our needs
now the tragic thing is that we're
losing so much of this linguistic
diversity all the time so we're losing
about one language a week and by some
estimates half of the world's languages
will be gone in the next hundred years
and the even worst news is that right
now almost everything we know about the
human mind and the human brain is based
on studies of usually american english
speaking undergraduates at universities
right
that excludes
almost all humans right so
what we know about the human mind is
actually incredibly narrow and biased
and our
our science has to do better
i want to leave you with this final
thought
i've told you about how speakers of
different languages think differently
but of course that's not about how
people elsewhere think it's about how
you think it's how the language that you
speak shapes the way that you think
right
and that has gives you the opportunity
to ask why do i think the way that i do
how could i think differently
and also
what thoughts do i wish to create
thank you very much
[Music]